president jay bolsonaro moved the
heavens and earth to turn this special
independence day into a milestone of
brazil's history and of his own campaign
for re-election
his rally in brazil's capital city
brasilia drew tens of thousands of
supporters and a military display of
planes parachutists and tanks
even the embalmed heart of monarch
dompido the first who declared brazil's
independence from portugal 200 years ago
and proclaimed himself emperor was
brought over from europe to be on
display
polls show bolsonaro still trailing
behind left-wing former leader
if lula is really the front runner where
is he where are his crowds we are here
to show that bolsonaro represents the
majority he will only lose the election
if there is fraud and the people will
take to the streets to stop that from
happening bolsonaro moved from the
military parade to a political rally in
rio de janeiro his political stronghold
the overwhelming number of people here
in copacabana today are supporters of
jaipo sonaru they're answering the
president's call to show up in force
transforming what would usually be a
national day into a political rally
the president focused his attacks on
lula's leftist party
we have a fight between good and evil
ahead of us the evil has governed brazil
for 14 years almost breaking our
homeland now they want to come back it
won't the people are by our side the
good side
many are asking for the removal of
brazil's supreme court and electoral
court justices whom they accuse of
conspiring against bolsonaro
the president himself has been casting
doubt on the country's electronic voting
system
opposition leaders including lula
accused bolsonaro of abusing his power
as president to campaign for his
re-election on independence day
when i was president of brazil i never
used the most important national days in
our country the independence day as an
instrument of electoral campaign rula's
workers party has taken this accusation
to the electoral court
monika yanakev al-jazeera
rio de janeiro